oh hey my little darling Oh Matthew you
[ __ ] Maude this how think Whitaker I
have been babysitting for 20 years I've
seen it all
the thing is forest is a unique child
everything is gonna be fine I want you
to have a good time tonight you deserve
it okay good luck thank you
hey there forest googoogaga
I want I want milk you want me to get
you your bottle buddy I want milk okay
[Music]
this is a Baba I'm on Mama's milk I
can't I have mamas milk it's a simple
request wait yeah well uh you can't have
mamas milk right now buddy
how about we play okay oh why I wanna I
wanna play with my Legos okay yeah okay
buddy let's sec I wanna I wanna put the
smallest Lego in my mouth that's how I
wanna do it you can't do that
what first you tell me I can't Mama's
milk now became a small mouth what a
night this is a bad star break up force
it's dangerous let me get this straight
you're in charge of me in my house all
right for force it's time for bed I
guess then you gonna sing me a song
what mom always sing me a song before I
go to sleep are you gonna do that for me
okay
okay yeah yes I will hush little baby
don't say a word
keep keep singing Mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird put my name in it I like I
like it personal hush baby forced
Whitaker don't say a word
look I got Mama's gonna buy you a
mockingbird a babysitter
and if that Mockingbird don't see have a
good cry hey babe um I made a really big
decision without consulting you I went
by a puppy rescue stand on University
Avenue I had to
so I've got to tell you something okay
these rescue dogs have had some tough
situations and a lot of them take on the
personality of their owners
this dog was owned by rapper ice-t oh
man you you suck mod this house thing
okay buddy take it easy see nothin ever
been easy for me in my life hook me up
with a treat
you want to treat buddy hmm yeah that's
a tasty ass treat right there
now give me the whole bag okay one treat
is enough [ __ ] without talking to you
give me the whole bag of treats cuz imma
treat killer and a mother pamper me my
ass right up on this comfortable ass
sofa I'm gonna sleep on this [ __ ] -
I've matter of fact you know what mother
and [ __ ] I'm a pithy up here - no raise
your hand at me okay I've got something
for you little guy ha ha ha you wanna
play fetch fetch you both y'all
condescending mother I ain't your
entertainment [ __ ] you hello who is
this
come on Coco don't worry about the
mother back my [ __ ] cocoa oh I forgot
to tell y'all she gonna be living here
too Wow okay you got your little friend
here yeah yeah well you can play here
for a while here puppy playdate yeah
lady we go up oh dang that's we gonna
have [ __ ] come here [ __ ] are you doing
that oh no don't do that oh yeah that's
my Shih Tzu okay oh dear daddy here it's
about to get graphic in this [ __ ] yeah
how come you don't do that with me yeah
he doesn't switch this area clean
[Music]
Dario Strucker
don't go out with my friends no more
don't wanna hold your hand no more
[Music]
no I'm not in Hootie and the Blowfish
anymore y'all doing my own thing what do
you mean in Hootie because you you are
Hootie man stop I'm now Hootie I'm
Darius Rucker all right I used to be the
frontman for a band called Hootie and
the Blowfish all right but I was never
Hootie there was never a Hootie just if
I may if I may ask where the Blowfish at
right guys know people known as the
Blowfish y'all okay the whole band was
just called Hootie and the Blowfish
that's it it was a nonsense name like
Hoobastank or Toad the Wet Sprocket
[Music]
I see I get it now I understand hey we
got a pic y'all we got to choose between
Hootie or the Blowfish so who wants to
see the Blowfish
[Music]
and what's UT hey and that that hurts my
feelings y'all know but you said you
weren't Hootie no I'm not sir but in the
question you just asked the audience I
was clearly Hootie so you are Hootie
I'm not though
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
nobody likes you you girl well you're
different color than me and that's bad
oh yeah when you dress like now hold on
a second whoa mr. t never make fun of
the way a man dresses wait a man dresses
is his business remember that whether
it's overalls chains or feather ear is
however they dress it's not to be joked
about I pity the fool that judges
another man's clothing I'm sorry I
judged your clothing it's okay
[Music]
hey Scout there's a man over there who
said he'll give us candy if we get in
his van I don't know if that's a good
idea Timmy ah what are you afraid of is
it because you have a stupid name like
Scout hey whoa mr. t again never make
fun of a person's name your mama gave
you that name oh you made it up for
business purposes
either way it's personal I pity the fool
to make fun of another man's name mr.
T's a cool name it's a cool name mr. T
[Music]
hey scout
why don't do some drugs aren't drugs bad
I don't know if you're afraid of drugs
we could drink a bunch of alcohol YUM
that sounds good well guess what your
hair is stupid never make fun of another
person's hair Hey missing teen a
person's hair is the artwork that they
present to the heavens just like I've
been saying
[Music]
[Music]
the way I feel
[Music]
and for your information it's not even a
haircut it's a rare form of male pattern
baldness you fools
[Music]
you